quel plaisir de revoir notre bon vieux
yoyo des années 60 entre le maire et ses
enfants aujourd'hui les membres de
l'association qu'à part du marais
l'appelle le rara le plus important est
de constater qu'ils se situent encore
pire des générations sur console devient
essayer de recueillir des jouets qu'est
ce qui est appelé par an
on to be vieux apprendre fait chier
antan lontan et le nom cet atelier où
les stagiaires confection à partir de
matériaux de récupération leur peau
autres spécimens ou l'aidant
effectivement c'est de redécouvrir ce
qu'ils ont créé
ah bon avec quoi ils jouaient avant et
voulait me dit c'est sympa puisque maman
papa tati sont avec eux rigual avec eux
donc ils prennent plaisir à découvrir
ici les stagiaires réalise des poupées
en chiffon des poupées appelait
autrefois des matrones moment simon mypa
terrain c'est l'agent pas tous les
dostie maillot et baisse a été plus
facile pour des toits mon enfant par
femme grande et warranty technique et
ponctuelle et puis fukushima khoudri et
puissante
mclane acheter valoriser la culture
martiniquaise et surtout au tracé tout
un pan de notre histoire est l'objectif
de ce village découvrir les vertus des
rimes est gracié occasion incontournable
pour ses visiteurs les explications sont
très claires les gens sont disponibles
et ouais sont des puits de science c'est
vraiment très agréable
le bar à parfums depuis 22 ans ce
concept a fait ses preuves en martinique
il permet aujourd'hui aux passionnés de
découvrir de nouvelles senteurs g goyave
donc ça sent bon
nous travaillons avec le maximum de
matières locales dont l'alcool issu de
la canne à sucre que nous avons donc la
chance de trouver chez nous sur notre
sur notre île les membres de
l'association j'aime ma technique sont
satisfaits de la fréquentation de cette
troisième édition dédiée à la culture et
surtout à la langue créole